no
my father does not kiss his children
like that Gwendolyn Brown shuts down
disturbing fan speculation about her dad
Cody Brown and her sister Aurora it's
easy to start pointing the other ugly
finger to blame during the Sister Wives
Stars YouTube recap show Gwendolyn who
is Cody's daughter with his ex Christine
Brown answered some fan questions and
was shocked when one van asked if the
photo circulating on the internet of
Cody quote making out with his
stepdaughter Aurora was real no
my father does not kiss his children
like that like obviously as kids we give
them a little smooch because of children
but no that's not how that's not not at
all I'm so sorry you were tricked to
thinking that that's horrifying
ET has reached out to Cody for comment
Aurora is the 19 year old daughter of
Cody's fourth wife Robin and Robin's ex
David Jessup Cody officially adopted
Aurora and her siblings after legally
marrying Robin in 2014. just whatever
makes them happy whatever their path is
is the most important thing
as for Gwendolyn she hasn't shied away
from sharing her hot takes on her family
and their TLC series during her season
17 Recaps in fact she recently called
out Robin I don't really like her as a
person watching her makes me like her
less for sure even though we have issues
in our family we are always working
towards working it out and becoming
stronger as a family
a big focus of season 17 Christine's
decision to leave Cody after 25 years of
spiritual marriage a decision Gwendolyn
says she supports you never tried to
have really good relationship with these
other people
and that's the reason I'm pissed off
that's not true it's just I did man just
the knife in the kidneys over all these
years I was like you're leaving good for
you she told me that she was moving and
also divorcing my father I like the same
time so I was like all hyped for her I
like my life so much better now E.T
chatted with Christine back in October
nearly a year after she and the family
patriarch decided to call it quits you
know it's hard it's difficult right now
I'm requiring a bit of a distance I'm
just starting to get to know me and I
really like me and I want to keep it
that way now Christine says she's single
but she's open to finding love again I'm
dating just for fun just keeping
everything super like nothing serious
just very very casually as for Cody on
Tuesday he and his first wife Mary
officially announced their split on
Instagram after fans watched what was
left of their relationship crumble on
screen he's like like we're not married
we're not acting as married and I said
to him then if that's where we are don't
you think that we should address that
publicly and he said no I don't want to
address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly now the
former couple says they are committed to
kindness and respect toward each other
we're trying to be honest about how we
feel Cody is also separated from his
second wife Janelle his only remaining
marriage is to his fourth wife Robin and
while we wait to see how it all shakes
out on Sister Wives we'll definitely be
tuning in to hear what Gwendolyn has to
say about it along the way I don't
really like her as a person
[Music]
foreign
[Music]